Софія Федина будь
ласка чого боїться Верховна
рада Чого Боїться
монобільшість Якщо ви не замазані в
цьому питанні Чому ви
боїтеся створити тимчасову слідчу
комісію Чи бояться люди які замішані у
цьому
питанніщо має проблеми то тимчасова
слідча комісія розгляне усі факти
заслухає усіх потенційних свідків знайде
проблематику і тоді буде робити висновки
але з огляду на те що влада так активно
блокує створення цієї комісії у громадян
України назріває висновок так причетні
так державна зрада була і я найвище
керівництво держави покриває цю державну
зраду Бо інакше я не можу пояснити того
що
відбувається коли я сказала що на
передовій стріляють і там розриваються
гранати то які крики піднялися всі були
Перепрошую такі борзі і активні А коли
сьогодні йдеться про те що ми маємо
зловити посадити
засудити московських найманців які
вбивають не тільки українців а людей по
всьому світу і спецслужби різних країн
працюють над тим щоби зловити вбивць з
приватної військової компанії імені
Путіна українська влада чомусь
старається якомога більше закрити і
замовчати це
питання Тоді логічно напрошується
питання А Кому служити панове А може
тому самому
Путіну бо я не розумію чому Так
відбувається і сьогодні
кожен хто блокує створення
ТСК сьогодні кожен хто замовчує це
питання є посібником вбивць убивць наших
десантників з
іл-76 Який літак збили вагнерівці І за
це отримали ордени від Путіна
є посібником вбивць людей в різних інших
країнах і відповідь окремим колегам яких
дуже муляє
Майдан на Майдані ситуація сталася така
завдяки тому щоб Путін і московські
найманці типу декого хто навіть сидить у
цій залі зробили все щоб знищити
українську націю і слава Богу ми дали
відсіч і я дуже Маю надію що у фракції
монобільшості сьогодні є ті люди які
готові захищати не якусь ефемерну партію
чи ще щось А готові захищати українців
від вбивць Дякую Слава